hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I am officially back yes yes back in
more ways than one I am back in LA my
voice is back in commission I am back
from Christmas vacation
and my hair is back to its normal color
and I know what you're all thinking
I hear it being screamed into the
comments section below right alongside
all those spam bots why why and I know
that's a perfectly logical and and
reasonable question to ask but yes my
hair is back to its original color and
no it didn't all grow out it is actually
been dyed back to my original color it's
a pretty good job you can still see a
little bit of red through there but I am
very happy to be back in my natural hair
color and answer the question why so
when I dyed it back in September of 2015
last last year I can say now I did it
for the charity stream because we raised
a certain amount of money I dyed my hair
bright pink because that's what I
promised and I kept it I kept it because
I thought it looked good yeah I didn't
care what anybody said I looked [ __ ]
great I looked amazing with it and I
really liked it and I kept it for
another few other personal reasons and I
thought it was really good but I'd never
intended it to be a permanent fixture I
didn't even intend for it to be there
for like a year it was really
interesting because in the past year
I've been to a couple of my friends
weddings and now forever when I look
back at those wedding photos I'm gonna
see me in bright red hair so that's a
thing that's gonna be there for eternity
and forever but I'd always intended to
go back to my original hair color
because number one and anyone who has
colored hair knows this it's a [ __ ]
nightmare to maintain you would not
believe the [ __ ] you
have to do just to keep your hair a
bright vibrant [ __ ] red like my god
it's obscene you have to go like every
month to get it touched up and then for
like a few days after that your hair
just bleeds out red everywhere stains
absolutely everything in your house and
in my house I'm an idiot enough that I
have white towels what kind I haven't
even bought red towels in the entire
year that I've met red hair I have not
bought red towels what kind of idiot am
i already don't [ __ ] anyway so there's a
number of other reasons why I wanted to
go back but I'm very happy to be back to
my original color and eventually it'll
all grow out and then just be all
natural and not guy black so those are
the reasons to quell those thoughts yes
I know it's jarring and I'm wearing
glasses again what's up with that it's
it's a new year and I've got a lot of
things and I'm committed to but I'll get
to that in a second we've got more
important things
ok alright that's enough celebrating
that was exactly the amount of
celebrating quota you do so I have an
idea it's my sweet 16 and I don't know a
creepy that sounds but um yeah okay
that's the theme of this so basically
were at 16 million subscribers and I
found a little test it's called the
mental age test and what it does is you
answer a few questions and it determines
what your mental age is so I'm a 27 year
old man adult man and I have a little
wager to put against this because people
seem to think that I'm an immature man
baby people have called me as such on
the internet but I'm out I am an
immature adult and I know exactly what
I'm doing in my life so here's the wager
if yeah if if I take this test and it
says that my mental age is 16 or lower I
will allow Tyler and Ethan to subject me
with whatever punishment they deem
worthy and I will accept it no matter
what it is they are I'm writing a blank
check to them to torture me in whatever
way they see fit it could be mental
torture it could be physical torture it
could be the tennis ball launcher to the
balls which is an option on the table
because I'm confident that I am mature I
don't know why I'm laughing I'm a mature
adult with mature thoughts in my head if
it's 16 or lower they're gonna torture
me if it's 17 and up I'm good if it's 27
on the dot subscribers okay so this is
the mental age test and it's pretty
simple there's 20 statements the answers
are multiple-choice your first answer is
your final answer statements are
selected at random millions of people
have taken this test so the stakes are
pretty high and the average age is
actually 23 so I got a pretty good
chance of walking out of here with my
testicles intact okay
the best thing on TV is oh boy there's
never anything good on TV I hope that
means I'm an old man you've forgotten
where to put your keys
oh no literally always twice already
today Oh No
I'm old I'm old and forgetful I'm an old
man you read Apple have launched a new
iPhone you think [ __ ] I got this one as
soon as it came out I'm an [ __ ]
birthdays are [ __ ] I don't want any
presents I don't want anything to happen
on my birthday if I can do anything I'm
gonna spend my birthday on someone else
something to ignore thank you because
I'm an old man that has had too many
birthdays you find an old shirt in the
wardrobe you
can't believe he ever wore that and
throw it out keep on decorating
considering giving charity put it on
wondering how they ever minutes fit in
it worked yeah wardrobe I don't know
you're talking about you get past on the
motorway buy a Ferrari you think but the
driver is a wanker actually what I think
is they'll not get there any quicker
which I'm pretty sure is an old man
thought you finish your meal in a
restaurant you do do to do make sure you
go to the toilet before you leave order
coffees empty the Train the bin ask
whether a tip is included wonder which
pub to go to I'm a I'm a cleanliness
patron of a restaurant and I always make
sure my tray is clean Twitter is huh
Twitter is essential for me for me I
can't answer that not essential
McDonald's is oh no oh god now people
can ajudge I eat more McDonald's that I
should every time I go there which is
more often than it should
I feel awful but I go okay for a quick
snack you're planning a house party you
think about telling your neighbors well
this is I don't plan parties so this is
not me think about telling your
neighbors find out where the cheapest
vodka is make a list of people you
aren't going to plan on which games to
play yeah I've just got to think about
all the people that I'm not gonna invite
because I I don't know where the not do
this option is yeah alright you see
someone fall over in the street do you
run over to make sure they're okay yeah
that's probably the best way to become
rich is to work hard baseball caps look
better forwards
dire straits were oh boy I don't know
I'm not good with music I'm not
musically inclined politically you are
liberal you think a pension plan is not
what you thought it would be important
something worth considering something
for later it's important invest early
this is an old man thing to say it's hot
you want an ice cream you buy a bag
you you buyer you buy a magnum um um
this this would you buy on a hot summer
day an ice lolly I'm beginning to think
that this might be a British test I'm
guessing this is like a fruit popsicle
type thing so I'll go with that one your
Prime Minister president looks HeLa he
looks all right
old Miley Cyrus is like so over a bit
racy quite good-looking everything
that's wrong with kids today a victim
these are none of the choices that I
want to answer like so over I haven't
heard anything about Miley Cyrus in a
while then again I don't look the iPad
is maybe there's like a - hidden here me
is there like some sort of coup so that
punishment it's gonna have to be in
another video because Ethan is not home
yet but I'm gonna call him boy
hey are you busy right now
[Applause]
you're upside down okay so I'm recording
a video and I was recording a video to
celebrate sixteen million so I had this
bet there's the mental age test which is
like you answer questions and it
determines your age so I said I said if
it said my mental age was sixteen and
under I would let you and Tyler pick
whatever punishment you want on me and I
said if he was seventeen or over I'd be
totally fine um it said I was I had a
mental age of seven yeah so when you get
here tomorrow decide what to do and then
go easy on me I don't know how I thought
I was answering old people answers
horrible I can't help that I know I
think it was bugged that's a good kid
the two I'm not sure thank you I think
why why maybe I could try it again maybe
it maybe I could try it again not really
much that could yep okay all right well
sevens what it is unless that's a joke I
don't know anyway that is that and we
will do that and that is cool that that
is happening but the bottom line is
thank you everybody so much for sixteen
million subscribers that's an
astonishing number of people I'm just
grateful every day that I get to make
videos for you guys and I can't wait to
get through this year just some of the
I'll go over really quickly some of the
New Year's resolutions that I got for
the entirety of this year are to workout
every day for an hour and then to
practice guitar for an hour every day
and then also to learn German or a
practice learning German for an hour
every day and that's three hours of my
life dedicated to improving myself and
getting myself back on schedule and so
far it's been good
it's been really good but we'll see how
it goes once I'm in LA and we're making
videos full time again so either way
thank you everybody so much for being
here with me and thank you so much for
watching for so long and thank you again
for watching this video and look forward
to the punishment very very soon so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video buh-bye